you don't want to sit there and play
solitaire uh you can discover new things
hi there steve kaufman here again and
today i want to talk about
seniors
seniors not only can learn languages
they should learn languages and i'm
going to tell you why
so if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
uh if you follow me on a podcast please
leave a review i appreciate it please
notice that i've changed my background
here i've now got this wood paneling
and i've sort of slid my my bookshelf
off to the side people ask me if it's a
real bookshelf no it's not it's just a
curtain i've slid it off to the side and
now i'm
working off this wooden paneling
so the reason i'm talking about seniors
learning languages is because i had a an
email from a good friend of mine who
plays hockey with me he's one of our
group of hockey players that have been
playing old-timers hockey since we were
i don't know over 40.
so 30 years 35 years he's my age he's 76
or
77 or 75 on the two and he says
steve
uh i want to learn japanese can i get on
your system
i said sure absolutely now some
background he has been involved with
japan he coached hockey in japan in
sendai for a year and he's very fond of
japan and so here he is 76 years old
he's going to start learning japanese he
can say you know the usual konnichiwa
ohayo gozaimasu but he can't really
speak japanese and i thought to myself
good for him
and here i am i'm 76
and i'm learning my farsi and my arabic
both standard and egyptian arabic and
i've got sort of turkish waiting in in
the wings
and if i ever get to a proper level in
those then i might explore indonesian or
i might explore
you know urdu is sort of a transition
from from persian or i might go into
hindi and tackle one of their writing
systems
uh or some other language
swahili i haven't learned an african
language i might tackle an african
language all of that i have in front of
me
uh
next year the year after the year after
those languages aren't going anywhere
i'm under no pressure to learn those
languages i don't need them for my job
but it's just so much fun to contemplate
that i can go and learn these languages
and
you know discover
like i'm now discovering especially with
the persian because i've got these
wonderful courses on persian history
that sarah has has prepared for for link
which i enjoy going over repeatedly and
finally getting a sense of when the
sasanian dynasty was and when the
safavid dynasty was and the mongols and
the the turks and the uh
you know the various uh influence of
rome and and uh fighting with the
parthian empire i guess they called it
in english
um and so forth and so on so as a senior
you know here you are
uh
you could be saying well you know i've
i've lived most of my life uh you know
i'm kind of uh
i mean you don't want to sit there and
play solitaire uh you can discover new
things particularly now with covert
where it's not so easy to go traveling
around
you can travel through your language
learning
as a senior
and and they i don't think you know as a
senior certainly i don't say i can learn
this language and then that language but
i know that there are a lot of languages
there to learn and every language i have
learned has brought me so much
it's like being at a feast where there's
just this endless
sort of table with dishes and you can
eat as many as you want and just keep
eating and enjoying of course we know
that for seniors it's very good for
their brains so even if say my friend
who hasn't really been a language
learner like i've been a language
learner all his life
uh so maybe it's like the capacity to
learn languages is not as developed as
it is in my brain because i've been
doing it more
but
it's like if you haven't used the muscle
you have to slowly
start using it small steps small steps
gradually build up build up the strength
and i think the same is true with
language learning regardless of your age
he might
find it a little more difficult because
he's not as confident he hasn't done it
before but
i know that anyone if they you know
gain that experience with a new language
listening and reading
they can learn
and of course especially today with the
range of
content that's available online so if we
take for example he could watch a
japanese series on netflix and not
understand a thing
except that there would be subtitles and
through the subtitles he would have a
sense of participating in an aspect of
japanese culture that is very
stimulating that encourages you entices
you to do more now in order to get
to the point where he could understand
those movies or even some of them
and which would then improve his
japanese he has to invest in
the sort of beginner stuff like the mini
stories so there is a progression from
repetitive listening to relatively
simple material
to get yourself to a point where you can
derive more from these movies but that's
all there for you to do
those are all activities that as a
senior you can commit a one two three
hours a day to doing and it takes you on
this sort of endless journey of
discovery
initially for one language and that can
be
a few years i can tell you from
experience with arabic and persian and
if you ever get tired of that journey
then you can embark on another journey
so
uh not only is it
you know i've done videos before where i
talk about age not being an obstacle
but it's more than that i think for
seniors particularly who are looking for
meaningful things to do not many of them
have their meaningful activities and i'm
not saying that language learning is the
only meaningful activity and of course
there are there's physical activity and
there's social activity and family
activity and there's all kinds of things
that can give seniors a very full life
but i think in particular language
learning is something that has a lot of
benefits i'm not going to get into
whether it delays
you know potential you know alzheimer's
there's all these theories that it
stimulates the brain and protects it
from dimensions over and so on i don't
know if that's true
it's an added benefit
but i think the bigger thing is that
it's just such a rewarding thing to do
something that seniors not only can do
but should do in my opinion
and
i'll leave you with a couple of videos
that i did on the whole issue of age and
language learning but again seniors not
only can learn but should learn
languages thank you for listening bye
for now